welcome to this video w jen who bar or
you bar Snow name and them oops since
surbhi I am ok so let's do the classical
limbs oh yeah it should what are you
thinking of adopting this line for real
but I never check this in much detail
there's an interesting video serious
about this line by grandmaster Gustav's
on I know it starts like that but I
don't really know Oh with the bishop
that's that's unusual black normally
takes with the night interesting
Wow I'm a bit surprised because the
nights are not at all stable okay man
let's do this can certainly spend more
time and try to review this but again
that shouldn't be too bad
yeah d five ticks ticks and then I've
got Bishop a 395 stuff immediately
Bishop e3 comes into consideration quite
a bit as well now it takes you for that
ok
okay let's take an interesting so might
be five c3 is hanging that just
certainly to be taken into account k
yeah no not easy where's she going now
Quincy six yes this is a very
interesting idea I was thinking at sea
for as a move now maybe but I know don't
really know what I do after a six then
what am i doing now to a six
yeah maybe just this one I don't know
it's just very difficult he 694 Quincy
three Queen a false a pretty nice
compilation I think so she just returns
I didn't think of that so much hmm jab
so what is happening here be five on the
group c 1 and then be 50 maybe I cannot
go see for him even though i would like
to and okay let's do that
yes he for the very big stretch probably
be five has to be played yeah covering
c3 and trying to play a for now
okay I'm again my time management I'm
just playing the first thing that comes
to mind now ok so now like f3 + f1 I had
to give some material button and it
looks strategically nice at least
two bonds
maybe she can play just might be five or
something like that I don't know rook c8
can i take i think i can only hope that
I'm not blundering stuff it looks a
little bit hope it looks a little bit
and harmonious some stuff like I don't
know a five or so this one interesting
okay take it if I take your dough she
will tick with the ape horn that's not
so right so probably hi might want to
move the night not sure 92 looks wrong
yeah but I don't know what else yeah so
I probably played this to ambitiously
yeah for Knight f3 mate unfortunately
shoot no okay white resigns yeah I
should play that well I think I mean
it's a kind of thing we're here round
here i'm pretty sure that i should have
something i don't really believe in this
kind of thing where black is putting the
knights and in this way but it's
difficult at least I couldn't find
anything anything decent d5 take sticks
now prolly app why don't I play Bishop
f4 in this position this is just the
better move really sometimes it's weird
yeah but what we play and that's just
very stupid the bishop ish is far better
on a form if she takes now I can the
capture is good yeah something like this
is very nice for me which means that she
has to move the Queen somewhere and then
why does really just better one key
point is that the bishop 183 was kind of
misplaced in the game yeah like now it's
not really working
yeah and now I have to play differently
definitely Roxy 1b5 that we should be
fine day 5 is not really on I can go v3
or something it's so pretty normal but
this wasn't this wasn't working it was
was just too too aggressive yeah but
every wonder was that so bad here yeah
okay the computer just wants to take and
says I'm still okay this Bishop everyone
is not that clear caf once the engine
tells you that you look at it you won't
have to agree how does how does she win
this now it's not easy I have a pretty
clear idea something like no head
activating and this is not doing much I
wasn't thinking of not be five ago I was
thinking okay I don't want to correct
the pawn structure however after this
I'm just lost so I have to do a data for
civils bad that was a bad game but she
played it well is there a name in there
by the way I did check that right yeah
there was no name okay well thanks for
watching